good afternoon welcome to the IBEW 595
Union Hall this is a hall that I know
quite well when I was a teenager I
worked out of this hall on behalf of a
local city council candidate and for
over the past 20 years have work to
support the work of this union and the
work and campaigns of other candidates
around here so a very fitting in
comfortable place for me and my family
and my campaign team to work out of for
our campaign we started about three
months ago a presidential campaign
believing that we must bring the promise
of America to all Americans the idea is
that no matter who you are who you love
where you're from what your parents did
your hard work should mean you do better
for yourself and dream bigger for your
kids it was a promise I saw fulfilled
for my parents as they raised me and my
three brothers here in Dublin California
my dad was a cop my mom worked a number
of different jobs and they believed that
they worked hard enough I could be the
first in the family to go to college and
that was achieved for us but with my
eyes open going to college in law school
and working as a prosecutor and serving
as a city councilman in this community I
saw all the people who did not have that
promise fulfilled so I went to Congress
in this past midterm election I would
come home for Town Hall's and meet with
my constituents and at almost every town
hall with hundreds of people filling up
gymnasiums and churches I was told that
the most important thing I could do is
their congressman was to reverse the
course our country was taking go out and
find new friends and reshape the
Congress so for two years I went to 26
states led an effort called future 40 to
find 40 candidates in their 40s and
under who could flip 40 seats 28 of them
won I also after being so demoralized
just like so many of you by mass
shooting after mass shooting after mass
shooting in America was about to lose
hope
and then parkland happened and the
communities of parkland converging
communities and Sandy Hook and cities
where we never hear the names and never
know the stories like Chicago and
Baltimore in Miami and Oakland and they
march from the town squares to the town
halls to the ballot boxes and they beat
18 NRA endorsed members of Congress we
had momentum after the last midterm
election and I believe the best way to
seize that momentum with a young diverse
remember a young diverse caucus for the
Democratic Party and 18 fewer NRA
members in Congress was to have a leader
in the White House who could seize that
momentum that's why I chose to run for
president
I was excited by what I saw across the
country over the last three months
building on the work we did for the
midterms in the last two years I told my
wife and our staff and my constituents
and our supporters we are only running
for one reason to win and then make a
difference not a vanity project not to
write a book not to make this about
anything other than the people who
really really needed that promise to be
fulfilled for them so being honest with
ourselves we had to look at how much
money we were raising where we were in
the polls and to prove you were serious
we qualified for the debates immediately
made the first cut down on the debate
stage had a campaign operation with
staff in Iowa New Hampshire South
Carolina New York Washington in
California and move the needle on the
debate stage on an issue that I was very
passionate about believe that every
candidate should pledge that they would
support a ban and buyback of the 15
million assault weapons in our country
and I'm the one opportunity I had to do
that
our three frontrunners that were on the
stage with me Vice President Biden
senator Sanders and Senator Harris all
three said that they supported that so
we've achieved that communities across
America who
by mass shootings now know that at least
three of the frontrunners support this
idea that these weapons of war do not
belong in our community but we have to
be honest about our own candidacies
viability you know an American author
Louis L'Amour wrote and the Lonely
Mountain there will be a time when you
believe everything is over that will be
the beginning today ends our
presidential campaign but it is the
beginning of an opportunity in Congress
with a new perspective shaped by the
lives that have touched mine and our
campaign throughout these last three
months to bring that promise of America
to all Americans to believe that it will
be the next generation whose leadership
will solve climate chaos bring cures in
our lifetime for health care address the
student loan debt crisis and make sure
that we say enough is enough we don't
have to live this way anymore and that
we love our children more than we love
our guns I'm fired up to do that work
that I've already been doing in the
Congress to go back to Washington on the
House Judiciary Committee the House
Intelligence Committee and is the chair
of the steering and Policy Committee to
work on these issues but to carry the
stories of so many people I've met
across America I also want to thank my
wife Brittany our kids Nelson and
cricket bury a lot of fun on the road my
wife was a hell of a surrogate for us
she was a mom got a full-time job put
everything into her husband's Kim I also
want to thank my parents Eric and Vicky
and my brothers Josh Jacob and chase as
well as my staff led by our campaign
manager Lisa Tucker as well as our
supporters who made the small
contributions who knocked on the doors
made the text messages believed in us
every
that along the way thank you I want to
thank the media because I see the media
everywhere we go across the country
carrying your materials and your cameras
and lugging it through airports and
trying to catch me and ask the tough
questions that we expect in a democracy
you're not the enemy of the American
people you uphold the promise of our
Constitution of free speech and a free
press and I want to thank most
importantly my constituents the only
reason that a son of a cop who was the
first in his family to go to college
would believe if he could run for
president and elevate the issue of gun
violence is because I am around people
who had the spirit of risk-taking and
learning from their failures and turning
them in to successes I grew up in the
Tri Valley but it should be really
called T ry
you
it's just in our DNA here and a little
bit of that is in your Congressman so I
have no gift no regrets I'm excited
about what we've done I think it's
actually fitting that today as we end
this presidential campaign over the last
week I've been mentoring and helping a
working 34 year old mother of two kids
in the South who was embarking today on
what will be seen as a longshot campaign
for Congress in the south but what I've
really enjoyed the most about my work is
working with and mentoring young people
just like I had leaders work with and
mentor me
so campaigns will begin across America
in the next few months to reshape the
House the Senate City Council's and
school boards and I believe that those
campaigns are run on the issues of going
big being bold with the solutions and
doing good and the way that we treat
each other we will see that promise of
America fulfilled for all men look bad
I'd be happier taking I don't know yet
I'm really impressed by this field if
Megan Rapinoe gets in the race I'm
probably going to endorse her I think
she turns 35 next July
you know what I'm really impressed with
you know the field I'm not gonna make
any decisions right now look it's a
talented field and that that was one of
the challenges I think for us was and
had a lot of heavyweights in that field
it's going to take more twisty turns I
look forward now to you know being a
citizen watching the debates what are
you looking for as you look at the field
of who's there what are you looking for
and what you'd like to you'd like to see
be the party standard everything
I think these are issues of the future
that we face and we need ideas for the
future so student debt affects 40
million of us myself included climate
chaos at 12 years before the effects are
irreversible gun violence as parents we
take our kids to school and we worry all
day if we're going to get a call that
something has happened so these are
issues that are new and I think it's
going to take the next generation of
leaders and I really believe that the
best matchup against Donald Trump is to
have somebody who lives in the president
but never ever stops thinking yes yes
I'd said that I wouldn't seek both our
our attorneys have told us that you
could run for both that decision
wouldn't have to come until December and
that if we were still in it in December
I wouldn't seek both but you know the
the polls have had their way so here we
are in July I'm excited as I said to
continue this work I'm going to leave
here I'm going to an immigration
roundtable to address the border crisis
which affects our district with so many
migrants and their families coming here
so yes I'm excited to do that work and
as I said it's not just running for
re-election it will be eminent issues
like the work we have on the Judiciary
Committee and special counsel Mahler
coming before Congress next week
yeah you know people really do trust you
when they get those opportunities face
to face they tell you things that they
probably only tell their spouses and
they're really counting on you and they
still believe that this is a country you
know of fairness and you know order and
laws and they're counting on it being
that way and so I don't want to let
folks like that down that's why gets so
frustrated that the President as you see
you know you stand in the living rooms
of you know hardworking Americans you
see how hard they've worked to buy their
home they're not asking you know to live
a lavish life and be a member at
mar-a-lago but they just want to know
that your prescription drugs aren't
going to bankrupt them and so they they
just want they want you to be straight
they want honesty and they're
politicians they want equal opportunity
in their own you know it was fun there
was a lot of fun to have my my
two-year-old and my eight month old out
there with me and some of these living
rooms you know you walk in and they
immediately jump up to take the kids
it's like they're measuring and weighing
your kids as much as they're measuring
and weighing the candidates you know my
if I have any regret it's that my kids
won't remember this at all but you know
I hope they're proud of you know why Ram
and you know to other families who
wanted a champion is doing more damage
we need we need a candidate who's tested
I'll tell you that much because Donald
Trump is the best political puncher ever
in American politics
so whoever we send to that debate stage
with President Trump is going to have to
be able to take a punch throw a punch
and then unite the country at the end of
the campaign and that's going to be a
very special person okay so I think this
is okay this is this is needed
weaknesses will be flushed out and a
leader will emerge
what's your message to some of your
fellow candidates who are also perhaps
polling at lower numbers do you think
it's too private of a feel and it's time
for others to follow your lead and it's
a person it's really a personal decision
you know we we've looked at the upcoming
debate in the September debate we had
the money in our account to continue to
you know try and qualify for the
upcoming debate but we believe that even
if we have done that that we look at the
September debate it just wouldn't add up
and so again we wanted to be honest with
ourselves and with our supporters i if
there was a viable chance I would not be
standing here today
you know I from day one was running to
win and if that's what others are doing
that I'm sure they're assessing their
chances as well but if as soon as it
doesn't look like you're likely to win
at least in my case you know I didn't
want to mislead my family my staff our
supporters my constituents you know I
think it was it is a crowded field and
you had people who you know have had you
know high name recognition
two of the candidates have run for
president before that I stood on the
stage with you know we have a senator in
California who's running who is she's
quite talented and quite popular so you
know I'll leave it to you know analysts
to determine that I'm proud of you know
the issues we ran on and the team that
we had behind us I just wish I could
have done more for them in those issues
fundraising polling number of donors
what do you yeah you know that the
polling wasn't moving after the debates
and you know the donor number was always
going up but I was never going to reach
the point where we could qualify for the
you know September debate is 130,000 you
know what I'll be honest I've welcomed
those thresholds just as is someone
who's putting everything into it
expecting your family and your staff and
your volunteers to put everything into
it we didn't want to just screw around
here we wanted you know to grow with the
thresholds and if we didn't we're going
to get out and so I those thresholds I
think are fair and it's the best way to
narrow the field there bankruptcy court
right now so you can ask them they're
you know locally I think the win against
the NRA is really from moms demand
action the Giffords group every town
March for our lives Brady you know
they've put them on the ropes and I was
just you know a part of that effort and
inspired by that effort for us you know
the final numbers will come out to think
in a week I think ballpark ISM around
850 thousand dollars is what we raised
this past quarter with just under 21,000
new donors for the presidential
presidential debate approach no no I
would have just you know taking my kids
out with us they were really popular
[Music]
challenger persons in the way or not you
know I don't take anything for granted
I'm gonna go as I said right after this
meeting go meet with constituents about
immigration and the border we've got a
town hall coming up in about two weeks
so I don't take anything for granted
you know I beat a 40 year incumbent in
2012 who had taken the district for
granted and I hope the district sees
that these issues that I was running on
nationally or the districts issues that
people in our district have student loan
debt our district you know is seeing sea
water sea level rise in Union see that
could affect community communities there
our district you know sends their kids
to schools and worries about their
safety we pay it was a constituent
during this campaign who gave me an
insulin vial and said please carry this
because it's the only way you'll know
how much it cost to me so you know the
district the issues that I ran on
nationally are the issues for my
district and what my district will find
is a congressman who's reinvigorated and
ready to bring these issues front and
center I believe because we've ran a
credible campaign one that is ending
today but a credible campaign I'll be
able to advocate in an even more
effective way for my constituents
you know I welcome anyone who wants to
run it it's what makes our country great
is that ideas are tested I expect there
will be other people you know who may
consider running too and so I'm not you
know anyone that wants to run you know
should run and I respect anyone who
wants to run because it is a hard
decision to make and I expect that we'll
have your exiting the race as Tom Steyer
is mulling jumping in any advice for him
but it's rough out there but well you
know welcome and welcome to the race Tom
and yeah all right I wish you know great
well thank you all again and thank you
again to our supporters our family and
our staff thank you
[Applause]